Traductor: Denise RQ
Revisor: Sebastian Betti
¿Has intentado alguna vez
imaginar un mundo ideal?
¿Uno sin guerra, pobreza o crimen?
Si es así, no eres el único.
Platón imaginó una república iluminada,
gobernada por reyes filósofos;
muchas religiones prometieron
felicidad en la vida futura,
y a lo largo de la historia,
varios grupos han tratado de
construir el paraíso terrenal.
Thomas More en su "Utopía",
en 1516, llamó a este concepto
"ningún lugar", derivándolo del griego.
Aunque el nombre sugiere
un espacio inexistente,
con el progreso científico y político
moderno se despertó la esperanza
de que estos sueños pueden
finalmente llegar a hacerse realidad.
Pero en cambio, se convirtieron
repetidamente en pesadillas bélicas,
en hambre y opresión.
Y como los artistas empezaron
a cuestionar el pensamiento utópico,
el género de la distopía,
el lugar indeseable, nació.
Una de las primeras obras antiutópicas,
"Los viajes de Gulliver",
ha sido escrita por Jonathan Swift.
Durante su viaje, Gulliver
encuentra sociedades ficticias,
algunas de las cuales parecen
impresionantes al principio,
pero resultan ser seriamente imperfectas.
En la isla voladora Laputa,
científicos y trabajadores sociales
trazan esquemas extravagantes e inútiles
mientras que descuidan las necesidades
reales de la gente de la Tierra.
Y los Houyhnhnm, que viven
en perfecta armonía lógica,
no toleran las imperfecciones
de los seres humanos reales.
Con su novela, Swift
sentó las bases de la distopía
al imaginar un mundo donde ciertas
tendencias en la sociedad contemporánea
se llevan demasiado lejos
desvelando así sus carencias.
Y esto quedó demostrado
durante los siglos siguientes.
La tecnología industrial que prometió
liberar a los trabajadores
acabó por marginalizarlos en tugurios
y esclavizarlos en fábricas,
mientras que los magnates
se volvieron más ricos que los reyes.
Muchos ya cuestionaban el efecto de
tales condiciones a finales del siglo XIX.
"La máquina del tiempo" de H. G. Wells
imaginó la clase alta y la trabajadora
evolucionando como especies separadas,
mientras que "El talón de hierro"
de Jack London retrató
a una oligarquía tiránica que gobierna
sobre las masas empobrecidas.
El siglo XX trajo cambios más
emocionantes y a la vez, aterradores.
Los avances médicos hicieron posible
trascender los límites biológicos
mientras que los medios de comunicación
permitieron la comunicación instantánea
entre los líderes y el público.
En "Un mundo feliz" de Aldous Huxley,
los ciudadanos están genéticamente
modificados y condicionados
para realizar sus roles sociales.
Mientras que la propaganda y las drogas
mantienen a la sociedad feliz,
algún elemento humano crucial
obviamente queda desperdiciado.
Pero las distopías más famosas
no eran en absoluto imaginarias.
Conforme Europa sufrió una guerra
industrial sin precedentes,
nuevas facciones políticas
llegaron al poder.
Algunas prometieron borrar
todas las diferencias sociales,
mientras que otras trataron de reunir a
la gente alrededor de una herencia mítica.
Los resultados fueron
distopias del mundo real
donde la vida ocurría bajo
la atenta vigilancia estatal
y a cualquiera que no perteneciera
le esperaba una despiadada muerte eficaz.
Muchos escritores de la época
no solo fueron testigos de estos horrores,
sino que también los vivieron.
En su novela "Nosotros",
el escritor soviético Yevgeny Zamyatin
describió un futuro
donde el libre albedrío y la
individualidad quedaron erradicados.
Prohibido en la antigua madre Rusia,
el libro inspiró a autores
como George Orwell
quienes lucharon en la primera línea
contra el fascismo y el comunismo.
En "Rebelión en la granja" se burlaba
abiertamente del régimen soviético,
mientras que su clásico "1984" fue
una crítica más amplia del totalitarismo,
los medios de comunicación y el lenguaje.
Y en EE.UU., Sinclair Lewis
imaginó en "No puede suceder aquí"
cómo la democracia
daba paso fácilmente al fascismo.
En las décadas posteriores
a la Segunda Guerra Mundial,
los escritores cuestionaron
las nuevas tecnologías
y cómo la energía atómica, la inteligencia
artificial y los viajes espaciales
marcarán el futuro de la humanidad.
Contraria a la creencia popular
en un progreso brillante,
la ficción científica distópica
se expandió a las películas,
los cómics y los juegos.
Así, los robots se volvieron
contra sus creadores
mientras que la tele difundió
películas fatalistas.
Los obreros trabajaban
en colonias espaciales
dejando atrás una Tierra
con recursos agotados
y ciudades superpobladas,
plagadas de delitos.
Sin embargo, la política reflejaba
de cerca estas distopias.
Obras como "Dr. Strangelove"
y "Vigilantes" versaron
sobre la amenaza real
de una guerra nuclear,
mientras que "V de Vendetta"
y "El cuento de la criada" advirtieron
lo fácil que podían desaparecer
nuestros derechos en una crisis.
La ficción distópica de hoy continúa
reflejando la preocupación moderna
por la desigualdad, el cambio climático,
el poder del gobierno,
y las epidemias mundiales.
¿Entonces por qué molestarse
con todo este pesimismo?
Porque, en esencia, las distopias
son cuentos que advierten
no sobre algún gobierno
o tecnología en particular
sino que la humanidad puede
moldearse con base en un ideal.
Piensa en el mundo perfecto
que imaginaste.
¿También te imaginaste lo que
haría falta para volverse realidad?
¿Cómo harías que la gente cooperara?
¿Y cómo te asegurarías de que durara?
Ahora mira otra vez.
¿Aún parece perfecto ese mundo?